So you've always been on to speak Japanese since a young age.
Uh, with my mother. And, uh, so yes, I learned, I did.
I don't know if I can say I learned, but I.
Like, you just know it [inaudible].
Was a drama with movies and my mother and some of my family, uh, that, uh,
like I said, it's you, it's a family language, right?
So when you have to work,
you use a bit another Japanese language, we teach Cagle.
And so yes, you.
Said, can you go was like very formal Japanese.
Former, when you have to spoke with your senpai, with your boss,
it's a different, you have to put your interpreter up and you down.
Basically,
basically it's the bane of every like person trying to learn Japanese. Right?
Like, it's like,
it's smooth sailing until you hit Kago and then everyone's like,
oh no, trust me, off. If you think it's hard. Now, Katie, just.
Given up on the thought of ever I'm like, I I'm. Okay.
Because I thought that as well.
Cause I kind of was the same thing where I'd like, you know,
I don't speak K go to my parents. I don't think any kid does.
So I had to learn got on the job when I first started, like, you know, uh,
part-time jobs in Japan. And I was like, I thought I knew Japanese.
I'm told I had to start using it just through every conception about Japanese
out the windows.
Is there any comparison? That's even close to English with Kagan.
Um, it's like, oh man, I don't know what, is there a comparison?
What would it be? Like trying to speak.
Like a very old, like very Porsche and kind of, it's.
Kinda like, it's kinda like going from only learning internet slang till finding
Shakespeare. Yeah. It's it's like it's, it's basically another.
So you have to learn to speak in cursive. These codes.
We literally like it's it's like a Shakespeare play, you know?
When did like translation is it's basically that.
I saw there was like Japanese cursive. Is there like yeah, I showed it.
Someone was writing Japanese and corrosive or maybe like, like calligraphy,
right? No, no, no. Like legit,
like it was like a doctor's note someone had showed me. Oh.
No. Do it. Like every time I have to go to the doctor to see I'm just like,
I might as well die, but I can't read this note. That's.
Good to hear that, that transcends language that doctors just can't write for.
Somehow.
That's universal. Right? Kanji was hard,
but you go in cursive Kanji and I'm like, come on.
[inaudible] actuary.
When you have some animators, you have some notes of my senpai on paper. I,
I try to because.
What did he do? Yeah.
I have to do coding. It takes too much, too much time.
So I go to my senpai story. What do you do?
What did you the physician's easy to ask. Isn't it? Yeah.